[Music]
in a little to the left news okay
submitted by Bart NGO arm-wrestle yes
man had to move his entire three-story
house a hundred and thirty feet from
where it stood to avoid demolition sorry
I was gonna say demolishing yeah cuz
they're gonna be building a new road and
his house ended up being right on the
path of the new row oh and he just
finished we're not just but you just
finished building it recently it's a
three-story home they had only lived in
that home for about a year
haha so they're the government pay em
well the government did offer
compensation
well here's 500 bucks good luck buddies
no they offered $63,000 about four
hundred yuan this six ladies enjoy their
like we're gonna do it no matter what
hum I thought this is America no as in
time aw dude
roads cannot be built here like once
it's there's a neighborhood and
everything you know they've been trying
to finish the 710 for ages I know it's
not gonna be done to the 210 or the yeah
all the way to Pasadena Tournament
either go above the ground or they've
been trying to vote and propose all
kinds of things and but the community
just isn't having it yeah well this dude
since he had just he spent about a
million yuan or a hundred and sixty
thousand dollars to to build this
three-story home and it also took
several years to build it and this is
like his dream home so he's like I
cannot demolish it so you ended up
finding this company that specialized in
moving home yeah happens that much that
they have companies like that yeah
apparently there's this one company what
do they do just like Dave will hold on I
like it I'm potting a plant and you just
planted some Ross all babies take a
whole bunch of cuz you got like pipes
and all that [ __ ] - oh that's like wood
so yeah
from the foundation and they put a lot
of wood in there cartoon yeah it is holy
a slowly well it took a whole month
that's Egyptian style no it is yeah yeah
it took an entire month making a pyramid
right there office yeah they've been
taking artsy pictures Instagram filter
on yeah they call blue it'll be cool if
they [ __ ] just built the road through
their house yeah and then everywhere
else they just make a glass so then you
see the car yeah so it's like a house
tunnel and then you just keep your house
but you can just see all the cars come
by and [ __ ] code and because they're
Chinese are gonna open up a little
coffee shop try to hustle the another
house yeah Drive Thru yeah yeah luckily
they were able to move it in a month and
he ended up spending a lot less money
than in the sixty two thousand that the
government gave ya and ended up being
less than that and he paid it all to the
company some money he actually came up
because the government gave him more
money for doing that or like he ended up
getting a I think it's your mom vibes
that's like he feels bad yeah he's not
getting approval I that was that okay
it's funny because she's further away
from you know but should be apologizing
to her I know we keep looking at me I
don't can't smell [ __ ] okay at least
that okay thank you sorry for
interrupting your story okay so the
house demolition have you guys seen
those huge homes like half homes being
hauled away on the freeway oh yeah
they're like mobile but not really her
my dad said my mom said my dad had to do
that a couple times
oh he had to [ __ ] drive one like yeah
move a house like completely like oh I
don't know that is crazy after that how
that
but yeah that's crazy what do you guys
pay the money to get to get your house
move like that how long what do you just
let it go like peace it's your dream
home you spent so much money and years
waiting for this house I would drill the
tunnel and make the world famous [ __ ]
tunnel house damn yeah tourism man yeah
yeah they could drive through it and
then maybe we have to pay a fee they
even go I'll be the [ __ ] tunnel troll
I think I would have been in that house
I think I would let it go cuz now
there's gonna be a road right next to my
beautiful house I'm how am I gonna sleep
exactly you'll get no rest Joe no I'm
gonna have a tunnel house
it goes through you've thought it all
he's or you could paint the building the
exact scenery is behind and just have
the cars coming slam into the building
like it's a real business man yeah I'll
be cool yeah because that all-star
what's not yeah because that turned out
to be cheaper than if they would have
knocked it down and then built it back
up and saved a lot of times he's like
I'm so happy like this ended up being
perfect you know be funny if you refuse
in a government just [ __ ] made a road
that went like this or the house amazing
sounds like some China [ __ ] though or
made the house what a turnaround houses
the circles that yeah just hey man you
can never get out of your house of
there's traffic
I know get out like double dutch you
know oh no we're gonna go out is it like
a highway or is it just a regular road
apparently the highway and his neighbor
found out that he was also on the
construction path he's gonna be hiring
the same company you know what's funny
is that they didn't plan their city cuz
usually they zone it out and they go you
can build within this area cuz we're
gonna put a road there China's like do
what you want
actually we just change our mind you
know we want to put a roll right what do
you think
a huge it looks like a hotel I wonder if
they have building laws like we do
because their shits always breaking I
mean look they're [ __ ] moving things
with what Egyptian technology that's
gonna break in like three years
you know a lot of people are commenting
like oh that's so dumb you shouldn't
have done that there's gonna be a lot of
cracks in the walls and like foundation
it's gonna be bad Oh cuz they're [ __ ]
construction experts watch it is they've
been living there now for a few months
and no there's no crack fully a few
months tall I know no cracks in the
walls and they're saying that once they
put them and they put the house in the
new place that they built an even
stronger foundation so it's better I
think the best response would have been
hey I don't care yeah damn dude I was
watching modern marvels
you know how they show you how they
build some [ __ ] and then they were
building um it was either the Venetian
or win or one of those out in Macau
that's [ __ ] crazy like the
construction that goes into that [ __ ]
it's like you're building like a massive
like watch like all the little bits of
pieces pieces yeah it's [ __ ] genius
man and I was just looking at that thing
like damn dude I wonder if the quality
of Chinese construction is gonna be the
same as out here because they might [ __ ]
[ __ ] I walked into some hotel or casinos
in Macau and they're like super gaudy it
like everything is like marble and my
gold-plated like is just it's
exaggerated you know what I heard um 70%
of all these companies in Vegas like MGM
when all these guys 70 percent of their
income is from Macau really they're
making way more money in Macau
didn't they lost because they lost all
their Asian clientele to Macau because
they don't want to come all the way here
Oh like bucket we're just gonna stay at
home yeah and then they speak Chinese
and all that [ __ ]
I want to open up a Vegas hotel what
would you call it
Joe Malia's would be the theme it will
be post-apocalyptic like net well like
Mad Max I mean it's not like bad
post-apocalyptic you know it'll be so
good look like yeah it's kind of like
punky Oh Sony will try to take a bath
they're just rusty water people die
every day no yes Punky's pretty dark
yeah but it's like the cool like I mean
like imagine like if there was a goth
hotel right like it could still be
really close to me again no thank you
right and it's like yes it's gonna be
[ __ ] it's gonna be [ __ ] awesome
yeah Cirque shows all [ __ ] dark
search shows theme punch not like
Zumanity grass mush is gonna be like
Rome old Rome
what the [ __ ] your casinos confusing as
you watch me with the wrong thing I was
going more like that's gonna be the
entrance but the Colosseum is gonna be
like old Rome what did that come from
for the show for the show
yeah wrong yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah so
you want duels like a second Caesars
Palace is what you're saying yep second
Caesars but then the Caesars Palace they
don't do real old Rome [ __ ] old Rome
[ __ ] is like people are trying to fight
for their lives
yeah and it's like you know we have
horses versus giraffes and [ __ ] with
people we are the bad kinds the most
docile they're the bad kinds well horses
in Europe they're the one they're the
evil ones they're the ones that commit a
crime they both eat like hay and leave
you got throw honeybadger in there you
get a honey badger yeah yeah honey
badgers with something like that yeah
cobras oh yeah
and if you lost me again
scorpions oh you see on the big screen
will get the cameras right next to the
GoPro but it's not just corporate the
Scorpion King sister rock he's gonna be
yeah you're making it micro fine I would
love a hotel if it was like Blade Runner
and then Tesla was behind the whole Oh
like a Tron hotel I'll crush your [ __ ]
cuz it's [ __ ] gonna mess up my
business like you know like you go to
your room and you're with your wife you
can like not tonight honey and animation
or like a hologram you can [ __ ] I mean
just end up coming on the wall exactly
how do you feel a hologram though yeah -
I don't know the technology Steve but it
will happen on Blade Runner you can [ __ ]
the hologram later on you just get a
hooker to like blue flashlight you can
put a flashlight in there yeah solution
okay there's solutions every problem
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]